we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p the eggman has family in
italy and he called to express that they
are really confused about what is going
on with alabama and child sex acute
abusers take a listen to this hi Dave
so I married a foreigner and my in-laws
live in northern Italy I was talking to
my father-in-law um
two days ago Sunday night I don't know
anyway he was asking me legitimately
does everybody in Alabama think they
think it's ok to have sex with children
why do people in Alabama think it's ok
to have sex with children
is it only Alabama he had so many
questions about that and he really
wanted two answers and it was hard for
me to explain to him how Alabama just
likes child molesters I don't know I'm
weak I'm hard to explain the difference
between North and the South that I live
in a northern state so I'm interesting a
lot of people in Europe think that
Alabama is a state to have sex with
children there you go yeah I mean I
think I'm not on board saying that most
of Alabama is in favor of sex with kids
what is disturbing is how many people in
Alabama seem to be willing to vote for a
guy accused of having sex with kids that
part I am concerned about yeah Roy Moore
is probably still the favorite maybe up
two percentage points at this time it's
stunning that I mean worst best case
scenario he's winning by a little bit
worst case scenario for him I guess he's
he's tied or maybe losing by a little
bit but there's tons of people who are
still gonna vote for the guy credibly
accused multiple times of child sex
assault and but eggman the most
interesting thing about Eggman's
voicemail and of course every word in
egg man's voicemails are just absolutely
riveting but the most interesting part
for me is this idea of explaining to
people from other countries the
differences not just between the north
north and the south of the US but
there's really like depending on how you
you want to slice it anywhere from four
to nine kind of countries within the
United States that have really already
distinct cultures that is tough to
explain to people from countries with
really one culture you know and my
takeaway is that it's you know usually
it's not something you want to do
talking to your in-laws no explain a
complicated issue like this much harder
last thing I would want to do if I
had foreign in-laws is tried to explain
anything going on politically in the
Trump era in the United States I would
avoid that topic like the plague on the
bonus show today Papa John's apologizes
for criticizing NFL anthem protests I
still will not go and get pizza from
Papa John's
the feds are preparing for a new war on
kratom or kratom I never remember how
it's pronounced kratom your choice yeah
we've done an interview about that
herbal drug that many people swear by
and we will also talk about India
declaring war on unsafe selfies get
instant access to the bonus show at
david pakman.com slash membership or
through patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will speak to you in
what might feel like a very long time
from now but it'll just feel like a few
seconds once you click over to the bonus
show if you remember